presidential candidates on the campaign
Trail make all these promises that they
know nothing about because they don't
have the clearance to get a top secret
SCI clearance so they're just promising
what they're going to do against Iran
and we're not going to take any more
crap from you know people crossing the
border and there's no threat from the
Middle East and whatever whatever
they're saying they have no idea until
they basically get to the last four
people the last four actually get an
intelligence briefing
for the people who aren't familiar with
you and what you do what's your
background yeah I'm an ex-cia covert
intelligence officer I spent seven years
undercover and I left CIA to start a
family start a business and that's what
brings me to where I am today teaching
spy skills to people for uh for
everything from business to personal
life what's a covert intelligence
officer yeah so people don't realize
that CIA actually has two types of
Intelligence Officers so CIA has overt
o-v-e-r-t overt officers and covert
c-o-v-e-r-t covert officers overt
officers make up about 90 of CIA they're
all the people who work for CIA their
tax return says CIA they go to their you
know parties on Friday night and they
say hey I work for the CIA you know they
do disguise stuff they do accounting
they do Financial investigations they do
you know you name it analysis us but
then you have covert CIA covert officers
are actually undercover they their IRS
receipts their tax does not say they
work at CIA none of their Footprints
says they work at CIA CIA takes a great
deal of effort to kind of erase them
from the internet and make sure they
don't have a footprint that is
affiliated with CIA or Washington DC or
the US federal government so about 10 of
all of CIA officers are covert and that
was that was my 10 when it comes to a
vector for infiltration
are those equally used I'm gonna guess
the 90 must be significantly more
visible they must be the ones that are
easier for some nasty foreign actor to
try and get into yeah you know what's
interesting is there's actually a third
Vector that we haven't even talked about
um because inside the federal government
the softest underbelly is actually in
what's known as a private intelligence
contractors so private intelligence
contractors work for a different company
altogether they work for Raytheon or
Booz Allen or khaki and but they
actually work at CIA headquarters so
that Vector is the uh is the most
susceptible Vector for foreign
intelligence because those are just
commercial employees those are you know
they have a clearance but they don't
necessarily make a career in CIA and uh
and your overt officers are very
paranoid about being approached by
Foreign actors your covert officers are
also highly paranoid about being
approached by a foreigner but in the
middle you've got this entire this huge
base of contractors that support
everything from Tech operations to
covert action and they're not paranoid
about being approached because they're
just normal everyday contractors and
they're always looking for the next big
contract that they can sign to what sort
of tasks will the contractors do they'll
do everything that your staff will do
with the exception of field collection
actual operational core collecting of
intelligence in the field if you
remember Blackwater or if you remember
any of the private military contractors
I mean oftentimes those contractors are
called in to do some of the most
harrowing most dangerous work because
it's very easy for the government to
spend money and hire contractors to get
them operational quickly it's a much
slower process to take a staff officer
train them in a new language get all of
the administrative paperwork signed to
get them you kind of transitioned to a
different a different operation so
there's a great need for the Contracting
base but at the same time there's been
vulnerability in that base that we've
ident to find it yeah the ability to
expedite bringing them on board it also
comes with a similar level of increased
risk exactly right yeah we talk a lot in
the in the intelligence world we talk
about convenience and security and
convenience and security sit at opposite
ends of a spectrum the more secure you
are the less convenient life is if
you're I'm married to a I love my wife
I'm married to a wonderful woman she's
also xcia but she wants to lock every
door all the time so I get locked out of
my own house it's extremely secure but
it's just really inconvenient she might
just be sick of you she might just want
a little bit of room for one afternoon
you know yeah it just uses a security as
a convenient excuse she's also a very
smart or a smart girl I didn't I didn't
say she wasn't
talk to me about how the levels of
seniority work within the CIA I have a
very low level understanding that you
have the officers that are higher than
the Infantry that are higher that you
know how does it work when you get into
CIA yeah so there's there's definitely a
hierarchy but the hierarchy is largely
classified so I don't want to get into
how that works but I can still give you
a sense right so everyone at CIA is all
of the staff CIA employees your overt
and your covert employees they're all
called officers your contract folks are
called contractors so we'll leave them
out right but everybody else is an
officer there's Tech officers field
officers analytical officers you know
there's open source officers they're all
called officers but inside the ranks
there's different levels so it's kind of
like if you're if you're familiar with
the US military or many militaries
they'll categorize Things based on a
number like an 01 or an E1 which means
enlisted level one or officer level one
and you'll have E2 and E3 and et cetera
et cetera and as you go up in rank you
go up in Number the CIA has something
very similar right so you could call it
almost like a CIA one or a cia2 it it
defines everything from your authority
to your pay grade it speaks to your
level of experience and as you do more
operations and have more years in
service as you take on larger operations
that have a larger budget you train in
different categories your kind of your
CIA level will go up now the hierarchy
is a hierarchy because there's not
enough space at the top for everybody to
become a level 15 right or whatever it
might be so what ends up happening is
you naturally have a very large amount
of you know first second and third tour
officers and then attrition or career
progression just stalls and then you end
up having very few people who find their
way into the senior ranks of whatever
the senior number might be all
ultimately to the place where you have a
few internal officers who might become
large-scale leaders leaders of the
directorate of operations
leaders of the directorate of
intelligence leaders of the directorate
of Science and Technology but there's
only one person who can do that right so
many many people either find their way
out or or terminate at a lower level of
the with their career so you go from
this relatively clandestine or at least
um
non-public degree of hierarchy and then
eventually you get to the top and you
pop back out again and you're now the
director of some sort of operations and
perhaps you have to give press
interviews and you're now responsible
for answering to questions from
different people and you get drawn into
meetings and such like yeah you're
exactly right you'll get drawn into
meetings and you might even speak to
senders or congress people when you're
still inside that that zone that nobody
knows uh so that might still happen but
you're exactly correct you'll you'll
disappear into the ether until 15 20
years into your career you pop out the
other side and now you are you know a
reliable source for them to put on CNN
or to defend the president's decisions
in just in Afghanistan or whatever else
it might be I imagine that being in the
position where you perhaps have to
defend the president's decision to do
something even if secretly behind the
scenes you didn't agree with it but it
is your patriotic and employment duty to
ensure that the agency is still looked
on in the right light that it seems like
a cohesive well-oiled machine as opposed
to one that's filled with Discord and
chaos and strife I imagine that that
must be a difficult pill to swallow for
somebody that's probably incredibly
conscientious probably a little bit
disagreeable very very smart spent a
long time doing this thing he suggested
a particular course of action something
else happened that wasn't his choice and
now he's got to go on and actually
defend it yeah so you're not wrong for
sure there's a little bit of that and
then keep in mind too that the CIA
reports directly to the executive office
like the president is the head of the
CIA not in terms of the director of CIA
but Cia doesn't they don't go to
Congress they don't go to the justice
department they go to the president they
they're there to serve at the behest of
the president and the president changes
every four years or eight years it's
been relatively frequent that we've
changed every four years recently so
it's almost guaranteed that throughout
the course of your 30-year CIA career
half of the presidents that you serve
you're not going to agree with
um and then to your point about you know
becoming in we are all very disagreeable
people at CIA we're not hired because
we're agreeable people were hired
because we can keep our mouth shut when
we need to but we're all very you know
fire in Brimstone kind of we believe in
a cause and we're going to execute on
that cause but we are still you know
loyal and obedient to the hierarchy
um but those what ends up happening is
when you get to that senior level uh
those that can kind of swallow the pill
bite their tongue and put on a smile for
the public they'll get more press
attention than those who who don't and
that's why you see frankly that's why
you see so many Anonymous CIA sources in
the Press because everybody has an
opinion but they don't have the courage
to put their name behind it yes that
does make sense I wonder how the agency
feels about having somebody who hasn't
gone through any of the training who
hasn't gone through the psychometric
evaluation who's had security clearance
and has been had the finger wagged at
them that you need to not talk about
this but
basically has none of the fundamental
skills that you were recruited for or
the skills that have continued to be
assessed as somebody has risen up
through the ranks to get to some
highfaluting position
it must be
probably worrying I would imagine to
know that your
the the actions that you take within the
agency perhaps that would affect
history that would go down in the
history books that would make press
headlines or would potentially put your
offices in danger
are at the mercy of someone who
wasn't selected by your agency who was
selected for completely different but
when we think it is an interesting
thought experiment when you consider the
role of the president yes you think
about commander-in-chief but mostly you
think about someone that's going to deal
with political infighting and what's he
going to do about taxes and inflation
and the rolling back row versus Wade and
blah blah you don't think about the
military now and it definitely seems
like
um is it Tulsi gabbard she served right
uh
increasingly people who is it Tulsi ever
made that up I'm not sure I'm not sure
there's somebody there's somebody in uh
Congress that did spend a little bit of
time serving Dan Crenshaw would be
another example right but my point being
that there are not massive amounts of
people with military or intelligence
experience that are rising up through
the ranks and yet that uh pretty
important element of their job yeah you
know one of the things that we often
joke about well we we joke our jokes are
different on the inside obviously we're
not as funny as actual jokes we're
probably more like you know academic
jokes but still
one of the things we often comment on is
how presidents on presidential
candidates on the campaign Trail make
all these promises that they know
nothing about because they don't have
the clearance to get a top secret SCI
clearance a special compartment into
information clearance so they're just
promising what they're going to do
against Iran and we're not going to take
any more crap from you know people
crossing the border and there's no
threat from the Middle East and whatever
whatever they're saying they have no
idea until they basically get to the
last four people the last four actually
get an intelligence briefing they
actually you know are proven to have the
need to know so that they can start
making reasonable promises or reasonable
plans to the American people
so it's really interesting because you
know the American public even the the
the two the two
um
the Democrats and the Republicans and as
they go through their national
conventions and as they hear all of
their debates with eight to twelve
candidates on each side none of those
candidates know what the hell they're
talking about they're just talking
they're they're making whatever promise
they truly believe will resonate with
their constituency not recognizing that
their entire foreign policy promise
might be underwritten it's like it could
be undermined the day they get that
briefing and what is difficult is that's
why there's so much so much frustration
with the president on foreign policy
because they don't change their campaign
speech they make their promises they get
their briefing they keep their promise
even if they know they can't fulfill it
they keep the promise they keep saying
the same promise and then they get to
the White House and then they don't do
what they promised because the truth is
once you're actually the executive you
have to do what's in the best interest
of the nation and the best interest of
the nation isn't always the thing that
got you elected to office it's a tricky
it's a tricky game that they have to
play
how much can you explain to me about the
way that security clearance levels work
because I went down a Wikipedia Rabbit
Hole a while ago and couldn't really
work out and then there's Q level and
the tell me what you can about how that
works yeah so it's a very complicated
mess so I'll tell you what I understand
and and fully recognize that there's a
thousand people out there who are going
to disagree with me because they know
something else and that's totally cool
with me
so in large part secret secret clearance
is the foundation of it all it's the
lowest level of clearance
um sometimes you'll see things as
confidential or for official use only or
um different different other
subcategories but those categories
aren't really a clearance like you don't
walk around with a you know for your
eyes only level of clearance you either
walk around with no security clearance
or you walk around with a secret level
clearance
secret level clearances are actually so
common that there's something called a
provisional secret which means just by
applying for a secret level clearance
you get a secret level clearance and
it's called a provisional secret
clearance and you have it until you're
proven to be somebody that can't be
trusted so once you have that then all
the other clearances stack on top of
that so the first most logical one is
top secret top secret goes on top of
secret and top secret usually has to do
with uh with an an area or an element of
of sensitive information there's
definitions for all of them
um so if you can Google them to find out
these specific definitions for a level
of clearance right I think secret is it
could could potentially do damage to
National Security top secret is could do
grave damage to National Security right
and then uh out inside of your top
secret top secret becomes a bucket with
multiple different verticals
sometimes when I was in the military
there's a special compartment
information SCI tssci that has different
categories when I was in nuclear weapons
with the military those nuclear weapons
specific categories were cat 6 and Cat
12. the other 10 categories related to
different things aircraft
nuclear submarines movements of troops
you know tank weapons anti-aircraft
weapons whatever it might be inside CIA
we have further subcategories that have
to do with human intelligence so you
might have a human intelligence security
category that is specific to
counter-narcotics or specific to counter
proliferation or specific to
Russian operations inside of Russia
Russian operations outside of Russia it
gets super compartmentalized and the
more the deeper into the rabbit hole you
go the more you get that compartments
compartmentalization all of your like
I've also heard of Q clearances
cue clearances I think are specific to
the military I think they have to do
with with the people who actually create
codes that become the foundation for
communication and for nuclear codes and
nuclear launch sequences
um I'm very likely wrong but I do know
that a q code a q clearance is a real
clearance it's not just from the X-Files
wow and so we kind of have the same
thing again that we talked about that
almost hourglass shape with regards to
um your level of public exposure also
must happen here in that you start off
with a very low but incredibly broad
type of clearance you can see everything
that is secret that's not much in terms
of the height but that's everything in
terms of the breadth you get through top
secret and then you begin to
compartmentalize and you have the
different numbers or you have the
different subcategories but then
presumably the director and the
president the president has the most
high level of clearance that's possible
because he has to be able to see
everything across all levels of
clearance now I imagine that even the
president must be compartmental against
certain things that he doesn't need to
know perhaps right now yeah I'm sorry to
interrupt go ahead Chris just that it's
this same situation again right that you
can implementalize in and then you
brought the broaden back out again yeah
you know it's interesting when you when
you use that example it's a very
interesting example
um there are two things that kind of
that add context to it right the first
is that the higher the tighter the
compartmentalization goes the stricter
the
um archive and data management process
becomes so you know a secret piece of
information might literally be written
on a piece of paper and might just get
handed from person to person with a
little rubber stamp that says secret on
it and that's pretty much all the all
the positive control you have and
somebody might accidentally drop it in
the trash can or light it on fire or you
know whisk it away and give it to the
Russians who knows
but when you're getting to those super
compartmentalized pieces of information
like you're talking about with the
president every piece of that data is
archived it's strictly monitored there's
you know backup against contingency
against secondary and tertiary
monitoring so that if any of those
pieces of information are ever leaked
they can be reverse engineered to find
out where the leak is because for
example we would never suspect the
president of being the person who leaks
information I know there are some
conspiracy theorists out there who
suspect exactly that but that we could
actually track back the data points to
see was it the president was it the
briefer because every piece of
information the president gets comes
from a briefer was it the person who
wrote the article that went into the
president Daily Brief because everybody
there's a human being who writes that
there's a human being who carries the
president's Daily Brief to the Oval
Office every day that person just that
person could open that book and start
flipping away pages and taking pictures
on honest on their cell phone for all we
know right so all of that information is
really heavily guarded and monitored so
that they can reverse engineer and find
out where the leak is if a leak is ever
identified is this a combination of
physical and digital security then
because presumably the I know the
president's Daily Briefing is this
binder type scenario that gets handy to
him that's something physical right
those are pieces of paper with words
printed on them correct going further
back from that there will be different
types of encryption that will be
tracking on the encryption there will be
ways to work out has this I'm going to
guess that maybe tied in with the NSA or
something you may even be able to have a
way to search for like plagiarism at
University does this appear on the web
anywhere web scraping to see if
something matches something that was in
the daily briefing okay where's this
come from so there must be a very
complex
um combination of security protocols
going on here yeah for sure and I don't
think any of us are really again when it
comes to level of clearance there's no
need to know I had no need to know how
they protect the president's daily but
somebody out there does have that need
to know and that person would know
exactly how it's protected but you are
correct in in your assessment that
there's both a mix of digital and
physical Securities on the physical side
we call it positive control
positive control means you don't only
have one person in control of something
you actually have two people in control
of something so if you or I are carrying
a briefcase with something sensitive in
it positive control does not mean you
have the briefcase positive control
means you and I together have the
briefcase maybe you're the one that has
it in your hands but I'm right beside
you at all times maybe I'm the one that
has it in my hands but you're right
beside me at all times so at the end of
the day two people can vouch for every
step that that document or that that
code may have taken that's positive
control on the physical side and then
you've got all the digital controls
because your clearance and your role uh
dictate what you actually have access to
within a digital system it's not that
different from Corporate America you
can't be a salesperson and log in to the
accounting side of the software you
can't be an accountant and log into the
sales customer management tool so
there's there's digital and physical
elements that go into protecting
everything from the documents uh all the
way to you know who the primary top 10
terrorist targets are that are going to
get neutralized this week I'm going to
guess as well that makes any
infiltration or turning of assets going
to be much harder because you don't just
need to get the one person you need to
get the second person to correct yeah
everything's there because when we talk
about you know positive control and
physical security what we're really
protecting against is it's it's
Espionage we're protecting against an
internal Insider threat a mole uh an
officer that gets turned over we've seen
that and we've seen how devastating it
can be so now you know everything we're
doing is excessive security again on the
security and convenience very secure not
very convenient it can seem archaic that
in the modern day
you're still carrying around a printed
binder right remember when uh when uh
President Obama insisted on having a
Palm Pilot that got that had Security on
it
um there's just there's really funny
stuff that we just never think of
talking about something that's with the
president at all times you were in
charge of a lot of nuclear weapons into
ballistic intercontinental ballistic
missiles and stuff what can you tell us
about the nuclear football the
president's briefcase thing what do you
know about that yeah you know that's
another one of those areas that we don't
it's kind of a mystery in a lot of ways
but what we do know for sure is that
inside the football is a is a code a
code that authenticates that it is in
fact a code that was dictated by the
president and it's really hard let me
see there's a the way that the codes are
carried I've got this is just a small
piece of cardboard from my for my desk
right the cards are actually
um cardboard like this they're pretty
thick and they're encased in plastic so
if you've ever had like a glow stick
that you party at a rave with right you
know how you have to crack the plastic
and then Shake It Up to get the the glow
so inside the the suitcase is a piece of
plastic that's opaque wrapped around a
card and on the card will be 6 10 12
codes the digits the alphanumerics that
show that it's an authentic code so the
president would have to open the case
take this out with somebody with
whoever's holding the case for positive
control
the president would crack the plastic
take off the two sides of plastic and
then actually have the authentication
code in front of him and then he would
have to dial that into the briefcase
which would send the signal
Nationwide to multiple InterContinental
intercontinental ballistic missile bases
as well as the standing nuclear forces
that exist with the naval Arsenal and
the air Arsenal all simultaneously again
it can seem archaic that it's all in a
physical card inside of a briefcase but
that is the only way we can make sure
that nobody can pretend or artificially
hack into the system and trigger a
nuclear response am I right in thinking
that there's some sort of machine in
there as well with something that you
would turn or is that just in the movies
two keys that you turn Mr President can
you please make sure and then press the
button that doesn't exist in the
suitcase the the briefcase the briefcase
is there just to send a signal it's a
one-way transmitter right he puts in the
code it transmits it out the keys the
two keys that you're talking about those
actually exist with the nuclear officers
who are sitting underground in charge of
launching the nuclear missiles
themselves so if you continue the same
story after the code puts in the
authentication after the president puts
in the authentication code that
authentication code is then digitally
sent via something known as an emergency
action message in eam and it hits all
the nuclear bases in the US
simultaneously red lights go off and
every bunker every every even if you're
not one of the bases that would need to
be able to fire oh God so does that mean
that some alarms going to go off and you
don't know if your particular base is
the one that's going to have to press
the to turn the keys and press the
button that is making all hell break
loose for I don't know 300 operatives
across the us or something yeah so and I
we can expand on this too because you're
exactly you have it exactly right 300
people there are there's uh there's each
base has 10 silo each Silo has two
officers and each officer is in charge
of approximately 10 Warheads so whatever
that comes out to loss yeah lots right
250 300 or so individuals will have this
red light go often they'll pull up on
their screen a code 10 12 15
alphanumeric digits they'll type in
their code the screen will say this is
an authentic code and then they'll
follow a checklist that says you have to
turn your keys and eventually they'll
still go through the whole process of
check check check check check take off
your key insert it count down three two
one and then the person on the left will
turn at the same time as the person on
the right who turns but here's the thing
nobody knows if their missiles are the
missiles who are going to launch
because the code tells the system which
missiles are going to which Target the
actual operators themselves have no idea
no way so I might have I might have my
missiles might be aiming at some place
in the Middle East and the guy you know
the next base over some of his missiles
are aiming at whatever Asia we're all
turning but the code is what tells the
system which ones to actually launch
that's like a nuclear game of Russian
Roulette you just don't know which one
but presumably if you guys are on site
how close are the nukes to the guys in
the bunker pretty far actually oh so you
wouldn't hear a rumbling a distant
rumbling or anything like that if you're
if you happen to be the one launching
and you happen to be launching from the
closest launch bay you might hear the
rumbling you might also hear the
rumbling from somebody else who turned
the key and actually had it but their
missile is closer to you than your own
missile uh I understand yes yeah I just
that would be the uh foolproof way of
turning the key is it me yeah it's not I
don't know I don't need to worry it's
not me yeah it's interesting so the
reason we do it that way in the United
States to get exactly to your point and
I know you're you're kind of joking
about it but the seriousness is
we don't know the last thing you want is
to have a conscientious objector at the
moment where you need to launch a
nuclear weapon so the way that they kind
of keep the human safety elements
instead of making it something that
could be hacked the way they keep the
element of having it be human based but
prevent against the conscientious
objector is they make it so that
everybody has to turn
you know every time and then the system
determines whether or not the targeted
the who the target is now to further add
to that chaos we get those emergency
action messages about every 45 minutes
so they're not like on a on a shift of 8
or 12 hours you're not sitting there
quiet for 12 hours once every hour
you're getting an eam a red light a
siren that goes off that comes in and it
gives you a code you pull out a
checklist you go through everything you
find out whether it's an authenticated
code or not and then you do whatever the
authenticated code tells you to do it's
a constant drill oh oh no way so you
never know so they are constantly
sending you decoy codes to put into the
system oh my God it's a it's a very very
hard job and for anybody out there who's
listening who's ever been a nuclear
missile officer or who plans to be a
nuclear missile officer or who currently
is
I understand the pain that you go
through the world doesn't know that
they're they're paying but I understand
their pain and I appreciate their pain
and the whole world does too we just
don't know it yet
there was that story I learned about the
uh Russian operative who decided not to
turn his key even though he'd had the
instructions passed down and I suppose
that's the conscientious objector
situation you were talking about yeah
it's funny there there's a there's a
significant difference between how the
United States structures their nuclear
uh professionals and how Russia
structures their nuclear professionals
so in the United States we don't really
have a say here's the other thing that's
kind of crazy right if you're in one
Silo with your partner Chris and I'm in
a different style with my partner if me
and my partner like high five each other
and we're saying nope we're not turning
any keys we're done we're not playing
this game it doesn't matter if you turn
your keys our missiles will still launch
because the system controls everything
it's just looking for one authenticated
pair out of the hundreds of pairs that
are out there it only needs one and then
they're gone so even though it's not the
base that your missiles are aiming at
and the code is actually for another set
of missiles because you in your
particular Silo turn the keys that sends
the network a signal oh so this is
distributed as hell you have very fully
distributed decoys in terms of the times
that they're coming through you have the
two people so in terms of a
conscientious objector you've got
pressure from somebody else and then
you've got this incredibly decentralized
system that means only one pair
dude that is wild and in Russia in
Russia they don't have any of that in
Russia so in the it's partly because in
the U.S your your Junior officers are
the ones in charge of missile silos like
these are guys 22 years old 23 years old
it's their first job in the military and
they're carrying a nuclear key around
their neck after going through three
months of school on when to turn the key
right it's it's amazing in Russia it's
the opposite they are senior ranking
officers who control the nuclear weapons
so in Russia they have actual command
and control of their specific Warhead so
if the president of if Putin says launch
and the person in charge of the missile
is a conscientious objector he won't
launch he doesn't he's he can go to jail
or he can do whatever but he has the
right not to press the button not to
turn the key and nobody can turn the key
for him right it's a completely
different model than ours Junior officer
versus Senior officer there's no space
for conscientious objectors on one side
there's space for descent on the other
side and part part of it's due to modern
technology and everything else but it's
a very different world on the other side
of the uh on the other side of the pond
speaking of Putin Edward Snowden just
got given Russian citizenship
congratulations congratulations Snowden
I'm sure that you've worked long and
hard for that what do you think what's
what's your thoughts there yeah so I
feel like there's a lot of I understand
the debate out there about whether or
not snowden's decision was good for
America or bad for America whether it
was legal or illegal whether he's a
criminal or a hero
but there's also a certain element that
you are Who Your Friends Are and right
now Russia just granted him citizenship
which shows that he is he is serving the
Russian interests you don't give
citizenship to somebody who isn't
serving your own national interests so
we know for sure that Snowden is serving
the Russian interests now does that mean
that that Russian interests were to give
away all of his Insight at NSA maybe or
our Russian interests simply to create
uh ongoing frustration in the Ukraine
Russia crisis right now by making a a
very public figure now a hero of the
Russian people
maybe but regardless what we have here
is we have an American citizen who
whether he intended to or not he is now
you know a representation of of the
greatness of Russia uh and and he
himself continues to be this
controversial character for the United
States itself and I'll go one step
further to say Chris that that what
Snowden did by by whistleblowing on the
the Patriot Act and the collection
against U.S citizens what he did there
is largely without question there's
there's not many people in the
intelligence Community who criticize him
for that specific act it's the fact that
he stole a bunch of other compartmented
secrets that had nothing to do with that
and he kept those as like a just in case
insurance policy and then he also
compromised those secrets that had
nothing to do with collection again what
were those what were the second sets
that he stole so a lot of those remain
classified but those were it was a
secret it was missions and operations
that we were doing outside of the realm
of counterterrorism collection within
the United States and the the fact that
he stole those and downloaded those and
carried them on a thumb drive and and
continued to use those as chips if you
go back and you look at the snowden's
history he moved from place to place
from Hong Kong to Ecuador to Russia and
every time he just gave a little bit
more right he kind of bought his next he
bought his next airplane ticket if you
will with a new secret and that's the
piece that makes people so upset that's
what is technically makes makes him a
wanted man in the United States not that
he whistle blue on on a program that was
later determined to be illegal but that
he took this insurance policy with him
that actually made him uh you know in
violation of the Espionage Act
unpresumably
Maybe
the agency knows what he has
but also I guess maybe not depending on
the ability to track what he pulls off
on a thumb drive maybe the digital
security be sufficient to know what it
is but he could have given back 10 and
still have 90 percent
correct we and nobody knows what he's
given but they do know what he's taken
and then it's to your point it's the
it's the it's the digital the digital
piece he only had access to certain
programs according to his clearance and
according to his you know rights he only
had download rights to certain programs
so we were you know that's that's
something that the NSA gets to deal with
on their own to decide exactly what
those programs were and what the damage
was
um but nobody nobody who is in who is
satisfied with solely being a
whistleblower takes the extra just in
case nobody else you know premeditates
how they're going to continue to flee
custody when they think they're doing
the right thing and I think that's the
piece that gets overlooked oftentimes
because everybody focuses on the program
to collect under the Patriot Act nobody
thinks about the secondary and tertiary
programs that he also took to help pay
his way to protection for the last
decade I guess he foresaw the
incoming shitstorm that he was gonna
have to deal with and this was his yeah
I suppose that that turns the situation
I hadn't heard about this before but it
it changes the situation from being a
single Noble patriot who is doing his
duty for the country to
someone that that feels a little bit
more selfish it feels a little bit more
like he has an agenda he's looking out
for himself and I understand the
motivation we're all looking to preserve
our own life and freedom and liberty and
who am I to say that I wouldn't do the
same thing in his situation as well but
I would agree I didn't know about that
but I think that you're right had he
have been the completely selfless actor
doing something to call the powerful to
account maybe he would have got
epsteined maybe not but he wouldn't be
the same type of um
distasteful actor I think that he's seen
now yeah and it's very interesting
because it just shows how you know the
lens of History especially in the world
of Espionage the lens of history is
short it's uh it's it we remember the
big things and we forget the small
things and in the first weeks and months
and the first two or three big moves
that Snowden made uh it all of this was
very public knowledge it was very
publicly you know we were all publicly
aware that he stole the the you know
this specific program and others but
then over time the and others became
something nobody talked about and then
now there's this you know huge movement
about you know Snowden is a hero because
he you know the the court system later
found that this one program was in fact
illegal
nobody doubt nobody debates that right I
even I don't debate that I just I've
always said he did the right thing the
wrong way and I know I get criticized
saying that that's a cop-out answer but
I don't know of a better answer than
that you don't end up a Russian citizen
by doing the right thing the right way
you end up a Russian citizen by doing
something something wrong along the way
how much do you think Russia could have
given to him citizenship to get access
to some of the information that he's got
and if he was to start to reveal the
stuff that he hasn't yet rescinded does
that I mean he's already
quite a high Public Enemy or at least a
private enemy an agency enemy I suppose
that would I'm going to guess make him
even more of a a concern even more of a
worry yeah what's hard now is
um Snowden is always he's always been
seen by the American government as a
fugitive but now he runs the risk of
becoming a combatant because now that
he's a Russian citizen if he
participates in some sort of uh cyber
warfare or digital Warfare or if he if
he assists their intelligence Services
operating against American citizens now
he's become a a foreign actor now he's
become a combatant in a large-scale
conflict that's actively happening in
Europe that to me the fact that he was
granted citizenship so close to the
mobilization of 300 troops so close to
the threat of nuclear uh retaliation out
of Russia against Ukraine you know on
the heels uh or on the the the front toe
tips of of a midterm election in the
United States this is very much an
information Warfare kind of move it's
not that he gave something new it's not
that he did something new maybe they've
been looking at granting them
citizenship for months they were just
waiting for the right time
but the danger that he has now is he
goes from being an exiled fugitive to
potentially being an actual Target
because you know I it depends on whether
or not the he rescinded his American
citizenship or if he retains his
American citizenship but we know that
terrorists who were also American
citizens became targets for kinetic
strikes
if he steps into that combative role or
that combatant role he may very well end
up on the same list
how do you think
the agencies who his evidence or his
um
confidential material relates to will
have reacted presumably when he took
this stuff a lot maybe it's about people
that are in the fields that they will
have had covers change or maybe been
pulled from the field or whatever and I
mean when did he when did this happen 10
years ago now maybe more yeah I think it
was more I don't I don't know the
specific year even but uh but what I
would imagine and this is me being very
honest I'm I'm guessing that most
professionals most Intel professionals
at this point in time they just laugh
when they hear the name Snowden he's not
a serious threat anymore he's the first
reaction is probably laughter people
scoffing and laughing at this guy who
did everything wrong even though he did
change the program like the court system
the the whistleblowing that he did
actually changed the direction of
American policy he's not seen as a hero
in any kind of Professional Circle
because of the way he did it so the
first reaction is laughter and then
shortly on the heels of that laughter if
there's somebody in the group who's kind
of more somber the next feeling that we
have is pity
because the guys outcasted he's never
going to have he's never going to live
the American dream he's never going to
be welcomed back in the United States
he's he's all he's gonna if you've ever
been to Russia have you have you dealt
with a Russian person uh Lex Friedman
and Michael malice but I don't think
that either of them are representative
of the Russians or maybe they are maybe
they are so when Lex is in serious mode
he's relatively he's pretty true to form
but Russian people are very stoic
they're very cold and distant they're
not warm uh they're not like friendly or
polite or hospitable like not at first
glance at least so that's his that's his
culture now for the rest of his life
he's he's there's no you know getting
drunken vodka is great but it's not like
he's going to be going to Margarita
nights and nobody's going to be bringing
over homemade guacamole and there's not
going to be you know the the ball game
um
tailgate that he's going to be invited
to anymore so he's got a it's kind of
sad he's missing out on all the best
parts of America even though he at some
point did what he believed was in the
best interest of America and that's
that's kind of something that's sad when
you consider it presumably all of the
stuff that he had evidence that related
to has now
access codes and maybe even the way that
the NSA Works in terms of hierarchy how
information moves around I guess that
that very quickly just got retroactively
and proactively changed so that all the
information that he had was basically
useless so that does make me think that
the Russian citizenship in exchange for
him giving them information kind of
becomes a moot point because you have to
be pretty thick to to believe that the
US wouldn't have changed things in all
in order to basically compartmentalize
all of that information to now be
um obsolete so yeah and to go a step
further than that it's you know let's
and I apologize in advance if I'm boring
anybody with this level of detail right
but when you give somebody access to a
an NSA program it's not like you're
giving them you know a PDF two-page
write-up about oh we have a program that
collects on you name it Iranian uh
generals you know traveling to Yemen who
knows you don't give them like you know
you don't even give them a 30 page PDF
you're actually giving them the source
code you're giving them the specific uh
ports of Entry the the the file and uh
and data infrastructure of how we built
it so if you can imagine giving someone
the blueprints to a house yes they get
to see the house yes they get to see how
the house is built yes they know where
all of the doors and entrances and all
of the events are but they also know how
you build a house
they know exactly what your measurements
are they know exactly what the you know
what kind of wood you use they have all
those details so if you could you know
apply that to the world of of uh Cyber
Technology if you could apply that to
the world of of offensive cyber warfare
now with the source code that NSA
actually uses to create a program you
know the Russians the Chinese the the
any the Cubans can reverse engineer
exactly how we create a program exactly
how we create a trojan horse or or a
false flag or whatever else it might be
so when NSA has to fix that they don't
fix that quickly
that's not the kind of thing that like
we very quickly and efficiently and
rapidly change everything you're talking
about we know that that because they
understand the blueprint they're going
to be able to break into five or seven
other programs that they've been
targeting anyways so we have to go
through this huge transformation to
change the way that we build programs
wow so the downstream implications of
him getting that information and taking
it off-site is huge in terms of the
workload correct it's not just uh you
know it's not like somebody takes your
the cipher code to your front door lock
and you change it from one two three
four to four three two one and now
you're safe again it's more like they
understand every nook and cranny about
your house they know which windows or or
single plated glass and which door jambs
are loose and they know that they know
everything so you've gotta you basically
have to leave that house sell it to
somebody else and go to a whole new
house and that doesn't happen quickly
going back to the CIA what sort of
recruits do they or what sort of um
talents traits uh skill sets are they
looking for in the role that you had
particularly
yeah there's you know it's interesting I
get this question fairly frequently
because you know we like to think that
CIA officers are kind of homogeneous
that they all have certain core
character traits in common and you're
not wrong a high tolerance for risk a
thirst for adventure uh a certain level
of of extrovertedness you know curiosity
natural memory whether it's short-term
or long term there are certain skills
that are relevant to you know a field
officer or a National Clandestine
Officer or a core collector or whatever
you might want to call them
but then far more than that are these
nuanced very nuanced skills because
cia's CIA knows that at any given time
anybody could be a spy right you could
get tapped on the shoulder tomorrow
Chris and you could go through the can
you could go through the farm go through
the training Pipeline and come out of
spy and he'd probably be very good at it
most people would probably be very good
at it the only question is who they give
that training to so the reason it's hard
to get the training isn't because it's
hard for people to learn it it's because
CIA is looking for very specific uh
skills at a specific time so right now
if you speak Chinese or if you
understand the nuances between Thailand
and China or Taiwan and China if you
speak Ukrainian or if you speak Russian
or if you speak uh Belarus Belarusian if
you if you are familiar with that area
you're going to be in high demand right
now if you know anything about nuclear
weapons you're going to be in very high
demand right now if you understand
Iranian drones or drone technology or if
you have a way of traveling to and from
Iran safely you're going to be in high
demand right now
two two years ago we were very
interested in what was happening in
Africa so maybe if you spoke yemeni
you'd be interesting maybe if you spoke
Libyan right you'd be in if you had
Arabic that was that was relevant in
Yemen or Arabic that was relevant in uh
in Libya or in Syria then you'd be of
interest now those same people aren't of
Interest
so it's it's like uh it's the it's the
flavors that get you recruited the core
skills are actually not that hard to
find in people
interesting I'd heard you say that your
profile and your wife's profile are kind
of different in fact maybe Polar
Opposites so yeah there has to be some
core competencies or core elements that
make you both usable but then also you
have these different flavors and
presumably you then get siphoned into
different roles based on those yeah
exactly right and uh you know my my I'm
more extroverted so I was better suited
to go out in the field my wife is very
very introverted she was perfect for uh
doing deep research
um my what but the places where we're
both very similar is we're both
extremely loyal the agency is able to
test for your loyalty we're both exactly
how do they test for loyalty yeah so
they they do a lot of uh psychological
evaluation they do a lot of testing of
how you're how your how your brain
handles cognitive information so you go
through a significant amount of
psychological testing and then you also
go through a direct interview with a
psychologist themselves
so they can actually measure your your
uh threshold for where you would
withhold information from somebody who
you are subordinate to and they can also
measure how comfortable you are in a
subordinate position so there are some
people who don't like bosses at all I
have a problem with authority but I
don't have a problem with authority that
I believe in
so if I think that I have a good boss or
a good manager man I am super loyal to
that person if I think my manager is a
[ __ ] I'm going to do everything in my
power to undermine them right but that's
a that's a Nuance that in the corporate
world nobody likes right in the
corporate world we're like oh that's not
really that's not really professional
but when it comes to who are you going
to give secrets to the person who's
loyal to a cause that they believe in
all of a sudden you're very willing to
take a gamble on that person whereas the
person who you know they always think
they're right and they never want to
believe anybody's better than them
that's not going to make a good officer
so my wife and I are both very
subservient to the person that to the
authority that we decide to subvert
ourselves to and some people are like
that and other people are not
is there anyone well known that you
think would make a good intelligence
agent obviously they would have to start
again and and not be famous but would
you have Lex as a an agent yeah so it's
interesting there you know I have come
across a number of people who I would
say would make good Intelligence
Officers so Lex is awesome I really
enjoyed talking to Lex uh I do think
there would be a good spot for Lex in
the intelligence world I don't know that
it would be in field operations only
because Lex really believes in the
goodness of people when you believe on
the floor what what a flaw When You
Believe in the goodness of people you
can't be out there lying to people's
faces it doesn't work right like you you
have to see people as tools as
Commodities as ones and zeros like you
have to take a very cold hard stance to
all people if you're gonna go out there
and steal information from them lie to
them and trick them into false
relationships that's essentially what a
spy does
and then you get that person to exchange
information for liquor or booze or women
or money or whatever else it might be
right that's not a job for somebody who
really believes in the goodness of
people but you know on the as an analyst
taking information and being being able
to make sense out of out of disparate
conflicting information and coming to a
meaningful probabilistically relevant
conclusion I mean that's what Lex does
all day long with robotics and with
mathematics right not to mention what
value he could bring in the world of
technology and the technology in the
Science and Tech part of CIA he could be
the guy that creates the next SR-71 so
that's that's what I'm saying there's a
space for everybody at CIA we don't
realize it we're all much closer than we
really think it's just a matter of of
the psychological evaluation and then of
course being being identified being seen
being discovered that's the hardest part
who else did you meet that you've looked
at and thought you you should really
consider a little change of career here
[Laughter]
um I'm trying to think of who else I
would know that other people would know
too so when I look at Celebrities right
Dennis Rodman would not make a good spy
it'd be really really hard to put that
guy in Disguise it'd be really hard
between the piercings and the tattoos
and it's hard to make that guy not look
like that six foot eight or whatever he
is as well yeah that's that's tough
right
um but then you have folks like Tom
Hanks Tom Hanks is like your perfect spy
like not only is the guy a great actor
but he is incredibly forgettable he's
just a forgettable white guy even as I
say Tom Hanks people might have a
picture of one character in their brain
probably the guy from Forrest Gump does
that guy look like a threat nope if
Daniel Craig walked into a room would
you notice him right away [ __ ] yes you
would notice him right away you'd either
be jealous of his good looks or you'd be
excited by his good looks or you'd be
immediately intimidated by his gigantic
frame that guy's not going to be a good
spy right same thing with Pierce Brosnan
like most of the guys out there who
would who are playing spies would not
actually make good spies
um it's not until you get to like like
Black Widow and Marvel Universe
yeah so you have you'll be familiar with
something called the halo effect or
pretty privilege basically that good
looking people seem to have better
outcomes as they go through life but not
if you want to be a covert infield
intelligence officer correct yeah if you
were to actually walk through the
hallways of CIA you would be severely
disappointed by the lack of Attractive
people
I'm just throwing it out like whether
you think I'm good looking or not uh
this is kind of irrelevant I know
objectively I am not a good looking guy
in American culture I know objectively
I'm not even a good looking guy in
foreign cultures because I'm The
Ambiguously Brown guy that nobody
remembers
it's it's it was a curse in high school
it was a blessing for my career right
there's a power to ugly so Call It
Whatever call it the corona effect
right the opposite of the halo effect
when all things go dark there's a
benefit there too talk to me about cover
Legends uh what they are who comes up
with it and stuff like that so uh cover
Legends come they come a couple
different ways so some cover is assigned
like no [ __ ] it's a very true story my
first day at CIA I walked into the
briefing room I was given an envelope
inside my envelope was a strip of paper
and on that strip of paper was my new
name that is exactly how it works it's
super cool sounding but the name was the
worst possible name you could ever
imagine think of like a name like
Herbert Malkovich or something like that
right like it was a horrible name and
that was basically the case for all of
us we open our little thing because
they're not just American names some of
us get foreign names some of us get
names we can't even pronounce right and
you get these names and you're like this
is my new CIA name and this is how
everybody's going to refer to me from
now on like Andrew Bustamante was not
the name it was it was some crazy I felt
like I was a white guy out of a western
movie uh from somewhere in like New
Mexico that was my name you just put put
together the worst Caucasian names you
can imagine and that was mine
so that's one way that cover Legends are
created they hand it to you another way
is they they tell you what you're going
to be doing and then they ask you to
create your own Legend and then
communicate it to the people who
actually create your Alias documents
your Alias documentation we call them
Alias Docs so in that case they might
say hey we need you to go to whatever
you're going to be in Pakistan you're
going to be uh in the mountains for
three months you come up with why you're
there and how it works now it's not
going to make it doesn't make a lot of
sense for you to be like I'm a famous
mountain climber and I'm there on behalf
of National Geographic and that's not
that's that's going to draw attention to
you so you've got to come up with
something obscure like Oh I'm a rock
scientist looking for you know a
specific type of mineral that only
exists in this one rock chain nobody is
going to remember you nobody's gonna
talk to you so are you optimizing for
purposefully boring purposefully
forgettable in the face purposefully
forgettable in the personality
purposefully forgettable in the story
exactly right you want to be the kind of
person that walks into a room nobody
notices you you have a couple of
conversations because you have to you're
trying to get information and then you
leave and nobody even remembers that you
were there that's what clandestine is
clandestine means so secret that people
don't even realize you are a threat when
you're in front of them that's a true
clandestine professional
if somebody is in
Deep Cover whatever it is deep
infiltration presumably they're going to
spend more and more time around the
people that they're trying to infiltrate
how do
officers avoid losing themselves if
they've spent a long time with other
people Stockholm syndrome or the
equivalent it's it every drug gang movie
where you don't know if the agent is
actually still working for the police or
if he's completely gone undercover
because now he's got a mohawk and a lot
of tattoos and that's the point of entry
right that's the vector of the
interesting drama how do officers stop
that from happening to themselves yeah
there's there's a couple of ways and and
and to be honest we know that you can't
really stop it the longer you're in Deep
Cover the higher your risk your risk
quotient is for losing track of becoming
insecure now we're not necessarily
worrying we're not worried about like
your mental health yes your mental
health matters that's fine but remember
this is still intelligence operations
the biggest risk is the risk to National
Security
so there's lots of documented cases at
CIA where Deep Cover officers stay in
too long and then they start to forget
who their true Master is and then they
turn either they turn against CIA or
they turn in favor of their their cover
business which isn't even a real
business or whatever they might be right
they they literally lose track of what
is reality because they've been lying so
long that they're now lying to
themselves
the trick that CIA gives us is that
we're taught to compartmentalize stuff
in our brain so we're taught to to take
a certain series of actions to go into a
role and then a certain series of
actions to come out of a role
so we always remember who we are in our
head it's the opposite of method acting
method acting the actor's job is to go
so deep into character they lose
themselves in the character and you've
seen the results of method actors a lot
of times they'll end up
self-destructing at some point right
the CIA doesn't want that to happen so
they teach us to put this compartment in
our in our head and our cognition that
reminds us you are actually Chris
Williamson you are actually collecting
information about this you are actually
on task for that you know these are the
five objectives you're trying to achieve
and when you object when you achieve
those five objectives you're gonna
exfiltrate yourself from the situation
so that's and then there's this process
for you to keep checking in with
yourself daily hourly you know uh every
every day at lunch time whatever it
might be so you keep that constant
guideline going but over time you start
to waver and when you waver when you try
to come back and walk yourself back uh
it can be a very damaging thing then you
start seeing mental health issues then
you start seeing PTSD you know pop up
um it's very hard for some people to go
undercover as a multi-millionaire you
know oil tycoon for two years and then
they come back and they're a government
employee making ninety thousand dollars
a year again it's not an easy transition
all in the name of American freedom but
you have lost your freedom as from what
you were to what you are now I suppose
as well that there is a a very difficult
balance to strike with those offices
because the longer that they've been
Undercover the better the cover is the
deeper their connections are but the
greater the risk is so a solution would
be to just cycle people out every three
months like you're in and you're out but
that reduces the amount of penetration
that you get exactly we are back to that
security and convenience piece again
right and you've got uh there the
built-in system to prevent that from
happening is kind kind of twofold one
your most active field operational years
are your first maybe five or six years
in the agency just like a pilot your
first half of a decade you're very
active in operations but after that
decade is after that you know five to
seven years is over you're in management
roles you're largely confined to you
know either headquarters buildings or
foreign buildings as a leader you're not
out there on the Leading Edge of
operations anymore so even if you do
have a very strong very effective cover
and if you do run an operation for three
four six years that's that's all well
and good but then they're going to bring
you back and break that system
and make sure that you are reminded of
your actual role in the larger
organization so they they don't let you
have subsequent operations in the same
Alias identity except in rare situations
and they also don't let you have
subsequent operations uh that force you
to radically change your Alias Persona
those are very high risk operations to
do and there's no net benefit because
like you were saying the risk to reward
ratio is skewed with every year that you
are in Deep Cover you were in the agency
for about seven years is that right yeah
does does this play into that at all I
know that you made the decision for the
family and so on and so forth but do you
think that a contributing factor of that
was you knowing that your most exciting
years were perhaps behind you absolutely
yeah that that's kind of what made it an
easy decision leaving CIA is never an
easy decision and there's a lot of folks
out there who know exactly what it feels
like to leave CIA the first few years
that you're in everything's exciting
especially for me I wasn't married had
no kids I was young and single I was
leaving the military so like it was it
was pretty spectacular to leave the
military and go into CIA and be the you
know the guy that goes and does all the
stuff that's in the movies that was
wonderful but then your your assignments
go by and each different assignment
comes with more responsibility in the
next assignment and then all of a sudden
that increase in responsibility starts
turning into increased paperwork and
admit you know increased administrivia
and increase documentation and you
actually start to see the the point the
points in your career where it's going
to turn and you know it's going to turn
it's the same thing that happens with
military Pilots they can see exactly
where it's going to change where they're
going to go from being in the cockpit to
sitting behind a desk scheduling the guy
who's going to be in the cockpit
and that made it easy to leave because
it happens right in that seven to ten
year mark and for my wife and I we had
just come back from a very successful
operation together and the agency had
told us now we need you to sit here and
train the next generation of people who
are going out
um and that we had no problem with that
in concept but in application they
wanted us to basically choose training
others over raising our own children and
that was where that was where we had
conflict
you met your wife in the CIA and you had
this after a while this sort of mystery
Mrs Smith thing going on what are the
rules about dating Intelligence Officers
within the agency I thought this would
have been a huge No-No yeah it's
actually much more common than people
think well again are not so funny jokes
that we tell on the inside we often joke
that the CIA is like the best dating
service in the world because you
basically have to lie to everybody else
but be honest with the people inside the
building you cut off ties with everybody
else so all those all those like clingy
ex-boyfriends and those you know booty
calls and those hookups that you keep
around just in case when you go into the
agency you have to cut off ties to all
of those people because every one of
them is a security concern for you so
you just you kind of start fresh so then
you end up you know meeting these people
inside the agency they're all very smart
they're all very uh interesting they've
all got great backgrounds nobody is
distractingly attractive like I was
telling you before right so you end up
having these very genuine relationships
inside and then you're like oh wait a
second like we can work on the same case
and then we can have dinner in the
cafeteria together and then we can go
home and we can do whatever we want to
do at home too and all we have to do is
not talk about work at home well that
seems easy enough
so there's actually a great deal of
intramural dating that happens there's a
large number of people who end up
getting married to other agency officers
because your whole life becomes the
world of intelligence and if you have to
like you don't want to go out and have
you know a happy hour with strangers
because strangers are a risk so you just
stay in the building and have happy hour
with friends in the building and
whatever else it might be so there's
quite a bit of that that happens
internally I suppose as well that if
although you can't speak about work when
you get home
you can be more liberal than you would
be with somebody who has zero security
clearance and isn't a part of anything
and you can talk to yours you can speak
to them in the cafeteria presumably
about the jobs that you're doing or if
you're undercover or whatever
so yeah I I totally didn't make sense
that it would be potentially an Adaptive
benefit to allow officers to get into a
relationship together because it's
actually going to I would imagine that
you will have a higher churn rate or a
uh at least more conflict within a
relationship if you do have to not only
compartmentalize at work but then
there's another one for the person that
you're supposed to be your all in
everything for the rest of time in
sickness and in health but not outside
of the office yeah it seems like an odd
way or a difficult way to run a
relationship yeah it is it is
interesting it's it's there's no there's
no convenience one way or the other if
you're inside if you're undercover and
you work at CIA there's no convenient
relationship to be had because if you
are if you're dating someone or married
to someone who's not on the inside they
don't get you they don't they don't get
the stress they don't get the risk they
don't get their debriefing they don't
get to know what you're actually doing
like it's it's literally how was your
day today my day was fine what did you
do paperwork you can't tell them any
details and you can't take them into the
building into a skiff where you can tell
them all the details it doesn't exist
right
but when you're dating somebody who's
inside now all of a sudden you at least
know the same people you have the same
policies you know the same structural
changes you have the same vocabulary so
where I may not be able to tell you the
name of the North Korean who I'm
stealing you secrets from I can tell you
I'm working on that North Korean case
that's driving me crazy and you get me
you understand what I'm saying right you
can actually give me a true platform to
commiserate or you can give me real
encouragement and that means a lot the
agency likes that because dating couples
spend more time at work dating couples
you know they they become two resources
on the same case and they're always
culpable for what information they share
if they break the rules then they're in
trouble if they adhere to the rules then
they're supporting each other through
the case that's a win-win for CIA very
interesting going back to the
conversation we had about Russia earlier
on how much of the Discord that we see
in the west at the moment do you think
is self-generated by polarization
because social media and Echo Chambers
and blah blah and how much do you think
are seeds that are sewn by Foreign
actors China and Russia and such like
yeah so I I mean I can confidently say
from experience that most of the noise
that we hear is internally generated the
whole idea that foreign actors create
narratives that cause Discord is proven
false in in many ways it's it's in case
studies it's in books that people just
don't read but it's also it violates the
core the core strategy and covert
influence isn't to create a new
narrative it's very hard to create a
narrative that anybody hears the the way
that you actually cause Discord or or so
miscontent is by just adding fuel to an
existing fire
so whether you're Russia or China or
Iran or whoever when you want to cause
conflict in the United States all you do
is add fuel to the existing fire there's
no lack of fires that people can add
issue to right whether it's the Snowden
debate or whether it's the Wikileaks
debate or whether it's gender or whether
it's woke or whether it's sex or whether
it's you know whatever I just found out
about something called incell recently
there's a thousand different things that
you can just pay a marketing company to
put a few extra ads out there that say
incel is the worst thing ever and women
should adhere to men and then you pay
the same marketing agency to send a
second message that says you know women
are equals and you know men who complain
about women are dogs and then boom all
you're doing is just pouring fire
pouring fuel on an existing fire
I had a conversation a couple of months
ago with a friend Gwenda Bogle and he's
got an idea around fire hosing that in
the Modern Age It's so difficult to
convince anybody of any particular one
narrative so the goal is to bombard
people with so many narratives that they
become despondent and nihilistic and
give up because at that point they are
the most easy to sway into one
particular you have two responses
basically it's the you know kicker dog
does a dog bite or does it give up well
either of those when you don't deal with
the biting that's that's fantastic
that's going to be looting and riots and
issues and whatnot and then the
despondency as well is going to make for
an easier country to roll over to
yeah it's interesting because the uh the
Strategic Benefit of it overall is still
kind of in the theoretical stages we've
never seen we've never seen in history a
country that's able to just roll over
another country by just devastating them
culturally like cultural subversion is a
a theory with lots of real world
evidence but no real world proof of of
of execution
right so I agree with you but then
there's also the element of the fact
that we just we're also all still as
much as we hate to admit it we're all
still adapting to a digital era we're
all still getting used to what it's like
to have smartphones and smart TVs and
you know you name it smart watches so
we're being we are choosing to get our
to let ourselves be bombarded with
information but we're also choosing what
information bombards us so yes we could
put out a thousand different narratives
but the algorithms in YouTube and social
media and whatever else are only going
to feed you the narratives that you
engage with the most so then you're
going to become the most engaged with
the narratives that you see the most
frequently which are the narratives that
you already believe in the most so
that's that's exactly the problem with
America it's that once you have once
you've told YouTube what kind of content
you like they don't give you any other
content they only give you what you like
once you tell Twitter what hashtags you
like that's what they keep feeding you
and everything they want to suggest
someone you might like nobody ever
suggests the uh the counter point of
view you know so it it just drives this
continued uh wedge between everyone one
of my friends says that if you want to
see into somebody's soul and work out
who they truly are look at their YouTube
suggested videos
I don't think that it's too far wrong
the algorithm on YouTube is the most
accurate as far as I can see of serving
me content there is every time I go on
YouTube There is five videos that I add
to my watch later playlist because I
think oh that's perfect and that's oh
brilliant dude World War II in numbers
how Hitler defeated the whatever
whatever yeah that's perfect for me and
then there's something about MMA and
whatever
um
one of the things that I find is a kind
of an interesting uh contribution here
is that when we think about our
relationship to technology and the
difficulty that we have around marrying
all of this together I think not having
a common enemy causes us to have nothing
to band together about as well
especially when the enemy is internal
because the tribalism you see tribes
relatively all the time they're
splitting off fracturing this group was
against that group but now this part of
that first group is part of another part
of that same first group and that seems
to be a very good way to
waste the time of a country
in not making progress towards anything
meaningful culturally by constantly just
repeating similar cycles and fighting
against itself or just letting a country
distract itself right so I don't know if
you have kids I don't know if you've got
nieces or nephews or anything but
anybody with children knows that
sometimes the best way to give yourself
a break from the kids is to just let
them distract themselves just give them
if you give a six-year-old an iPad and
you tell them they can watch whatever
they want to on YouTube
they will distract themselves and you
won't hear from them for hours right if
you give them a if you give any kid in
under the age of nine if you give them a
bucket of toys even if it's just the
toys from the neighbor's house next door
if you give them a bucket of toys
they've never played with before they'll
distract themselves essentially that's
what that's all a country really has to
do is just give the tools to one country
to distract itself and in that process
they kind of uh they're they're free if
you're hearing background noise I'm in
DC so there's all these I mean it's like
helicopter Central you got the president
and the Congress people flying all over
the place all the time so it's just
helicopter City very nice I was in uh
Long Island is that the one in New York
yes I was in Long Island uh start of the
year
I cannot believe the volume of planes
it's every 90 seconds pretty much 24
hours a day pretty much 365 days a year
yeah why the [ __ ] do you live here what
and apparently it's really really nice
and it was beautiful and I enjoyed my
time there but
that's intense that is an intense flight
path so it's something else that I was
thinking about and I this really came up
to me when uh last year the 20th
anniversary of 9 11 uh and I'm a Brit
you know I was
12 I think 9 11 happened
um
it hit home to me the way that it must
have had such an impact on the lives of
America
um with some of the documentaries that
were done you know some of the the video
footage that I'd never seen before some
of the testimony of the
um FDNY guys that had been going in and
I was on one side of a door and I got
down the set of stairs and my best
friend who I'd worked with for 20 years
was on the other side of the door and
he's not with us anymore just so many it
was really really moving I thought it
was an amazing way to sort of show
tribute and and
re-educate people about what had
happened especially people perhaps that
hadn't even been around you know and
something that I found pretty
interesting is the modern confusion
around the word conspiracy every time
that somebody brings up the term
conspiracy online there is a whole bunch
of comments that'll say something like
well you know uh yesterday's conspiracy
is today's top news headline uh and it
does seem like the word conspiracy can
be used to discredit genuine stories
that powerful groups don't want to gain
steam it can be used to create stories
that misdirect people away from things
that genuinely are true
that just fascinated me thinking about
that especially looking back last year
yeah I have a whole I mean I have a
YouTube video out there that teaches
people the anatomy of a conspiracy teach
us tell us well yeah there's there's a
lot that goes into it but there's
essentially just a few core ingredients
right so first there has to be something
that happens there there has to be some
factual event something that's that's
evidentiary something you can see you
can you can touch you can hear whatever
it might be has to be a kernel of Truth
somewhere yeah that's how every con can
uh everything has to start with a kernel
of Truth but then what happens is
immediately after that there has to be a
lack of information
so there has to be an element of truth
that's immediately followed by a lack of
information
now what happens cognitively is the
human brain wants closure the human
brain always wants to close every open
loop of reasoning so when you hear
something that's truthful right there's
an unidentified object in the sky
right then there's a gap of information
well what was it was it a plane we don't
know was it a helicopter we don't know
there's no information about what it was
now the human brain doesn't like that so
the human brain starts to seek
possibilities
so the third ingredient in a conspiracy
has to be a series of potential
explanations now in that series of
potential explanations here's what ends
up happening we forget we forget that
we're just going through a series of
potentialities and we start to think
instead that the potentialities are in
fact the explanation and then we start
to enforce the explanation that we
believe explains the original kernel of
truth that's how a conspiracy is born so
uh the the Twin Towers are destroyed in
9 11. two airplanes crash into them
that's there's all sorts of kernels of
Truth out there that let us know it's
real but then there's this break in
information how did the pilots get
training and when how did they organize
this whole thing and how did the police
not find out and how did CIA and FBI not
find out and and then even when there's
an explanation about how CIA and FBI
didn't communicate effectively
there's still lots of information that
people don't get we want to know what
intels were out there we want to know
what sources were out there but they
don't get that information
so then they start saying well why is
nobody sharing what could be in that
information oh it was an inside job they
don't want to admit that there was a
there was an element inside the US
government that wanted this to happen or
or there you know whatever else it was
the Israelis and they don't want to let
these you know they don't want to tell
anybody that's Israeli so these crazy I
call them crazy but these conclusions
these these estimations pop up in the in
the absence of information and then
people are like if it was an inside job
they would have been able to keep it
secret because they control all their
own information right and then all the
if then start and the if thens on their
own are valid right if you wanted to
cover something up here's how you would
do it if it was if if it was the Mormons
that did it then this is how they would
cover it up whatever it is it would all
be in there so because this reasoning is
sound and this fact is sound the
conspiracy exists even though nobody is
accounting for the fact that there's
there's nothing connecting the two sides
that are reasoned and well thought out
and without something to connect the two
there's no foundation in truth the
vacuum in the middle sucks in
speculation and the fact that nothing
comes out to disprove that and if you
even if it's something does come out to
disprove that after time the first story
is often the one that people cling on to
at least the first one that makes sense
so
there's this story from Matthew Syed and
this is in the times back in the start
of covid psychologists have conducted
experiments to shed light on why people
lose or at least suspend rationality one
experiment asks people to imagine going
to a doctor to hear an uncertain medical
diagnosis such people were significantly
more likely to express the belief that
God was in control of their lives
another asked participants to imagine a
time of deep uncertainty when they feed
for their jobs or the health of their
children they were far more likely to
see a pattern in meaningless static or
to infer the two random events were
connected this is such a common finding
that psychologists have given it a name
compensatory control when we feel
uncertain when Randomness intrudes Upon
Our Lives we respond by reintroducing
order in some other way superstitions
and conspiracy theories speak to this
need it is not easy to accept that
important events are shaped by random
forces this is why for some it makes
more sense to believe we are threatened
by the grand plans of malign scientists
than the transmutation of a silly little
microbe yeah that's exactly I think
that's a much more eloquent way of
saying what I said for sure and leave it
to a psychologist to do it right but
that's exactly what happens and we we're
all sub we're all subject to it it's why
when our wife doesn't say something to
us at the end of the day we think that
she's hiding something it's why when our
kids are you know are are extra happy we
suspect that they're keeping something
from us right it's because in a lack of
total knowledge a lack of total
information total transparency we want
to find some rational explanation for
our own uncertainty instead of just
embracing the uncertainty and to a
certain to a certain extent there's
Freedom when you're willing to accept
the unknown
was 9 11 the biggest intelligence
failure that the US has had
in my in my lifetime I would say yes
before your lifetime
um
the largest intelligence failure for the
US I'd have to give a more serious
thought to be honest
um we've had some pretty big
intelligence flaps right we totally
called it wrong in Afghanistan the whole
world called it wrong with how Ukraine
would respond to Russia
um the we continue to make wrong
estimates about what's going to happen
in Ukraine and Russia right and uh and
you've got 9 11 is out there and you've
there's lots of stories of of
intelligence Flaps in other countries as
well France and and the UK and even the
Nazis so it's intelligence is hard
that's just the nature of the game
we mentioned it earlier on what are your
thoughts on Q Anon
so Q Anon is interesting I I think that
there is
there's a level of value in
floating the idea of conspiracies and
here's why because conspiracies have a
kernel of Truth and we have definitely
had instances in history where a
conspiracy has proven to be correct
so there's always I don't I don't see
any reason to shut down voices that are
out there suggesting alternate
um alternate explanations to the unknown
but it does get to be difficult whenever
they start to
they don't account for the fact that
they could be used for malicious intent
or for malicious purposes right it's
like it's like cryptocurrency I'm all
for blockchain but when it comes to
cryptocurrency the only real true use
case for cryptocurrency has been in
abusing and circumventing laws that's
what made Bitcoin famous that's what
made Bitcoin wealthy
um now that we're trying to justify you
know societally Pro societally
beneficial or productive uses for
cryptocurrency doesn't change the fact
that it was born out of malicious intent
it was basically a hawala in the digital
world instead of what's a koala a huala
is how it's it's an Arabic term for how
you exchange currency without being
tracked so terrorist organizations in
the early jiwot in the early global war
on terrorism they would actually
facilitate Financial transfers using
rocks so a rock of a certain size would
be worth ten thousand dollars a rock of
a different size would be worth two
hundred dollars and they would make a
basket of rocks and one terrorist would
send that basket to another terrorist
and that would be their hawala evidence
that their that they were given a
certain amount of money and then they
would go to this dispersed Financial
Network and pull their money out of the
system
that's essentially what how Bitcoin
started as well it was just koala
without the rocks
dude that's wild that is so interesting
koala is still very active people don't
realize it
um they're active in Arabic cultures
they're AF they're active in Indian
cultures they're just they're not always
malicious but they have they have a
great deal of use in malicious circles
I've heard you talk a lot about
highly powerful Rich
individuals and the way that they go
about their lives the type of technology
that they have with backup phones the
way that they see the world and and
they're sort of um views operating
protocol in their own mind psychological
profiles and stuff like that I had a
conversation a couple of years ago on
the show with a guy called Daniel
schmachtenberg it was a incredibly smart
dude polymath guy and he gets himself
into uh similarly high level uh
conversations he told me this really
sort of harrowing story about he was at
dinner with somebody uh who is very
influential and has the resources to be
able to act act on whatever it is that
they want to do this person said
something to him along the lines of
Daniel had brought up some of the things
that he was proposing might be quite
damaging it might make people's lives
worse just not particularly good for
society and this guy said well I'm an
apex predator apex predators don't care
about what the prey do
in your experience around high-powered
individuals who both have the resources
and the network to be able to do stuff
Have you ever come across somebody who
you think it would be better if this
particular type of Personality didn't
have access to the capability to enact
their dreams
uh So my answer is no but you're you may
not like the rest of my answer so I
think that the apex predator attitude is
very much prevalent among the ultra
wealthy
um specifically around the ultra wealthy
who have built their wealth from nothing
I'm not talking about like Talent like
your actors your your talent people your
musicians that are out there your
podcasters right these are people who
become extremely wealthy but they didn't
really build their wealth from nothing
they built their talent from nothing and
then somebody else came in and hired
their talent so your talent always it's
objectively your talent works for
somebody they have a production schedule
they have to meet they have a boss right
they can't just stop producing if they
stop producing movies or stop producing
podcasts then they're not they're not
going to make any more money
what but a true a true entrepreneur a
true business owner is somebody who can
stop working but the business keeps
running right the business keeps growing
it keeps doing whatever it wants to do
among those individuals uh we call them
ultra high net worth ultra high net
worth in our world and our community we
Define ultra high net worth as people
with a net worth of 15 million or more
so that goes up quite High there are
people who are worth billions of dollars
but essentially if if you're worth a net
worth of about 15 million dollars you
have built that you haven't been given
that
um if you come from a wealthy family
it's a completely different thing but
you you most likely own a scalable
business and now that's that's the
business that you run and to get to that
point you have had to make very harsh
decisions you have had to learn how to
get into the mind of your customer
you've had to learn how to master
negotiation skills with not just people
but with banks with policy makers with
you know lobbyists whatever it might be
so absolutely in my experience around
ultra high net worth wealthy individuals
they have that apex predator attitude
and to begin to be very Frank I am very
happy they have that apex predator
attitude because without your apex
predators
who's going to rule the roost right like
do we want arbitrary unpredictable
leadership or do we want very decisive
very predictable leadership right if you
think of a lion a lion is an apex
predator a lion Remains the head of
their what are lions in Prides right a
lion a pride has one head lion until
another lion takes that lion down but
there's always only one and if you don't
want to be if you don't want to compete
for the pride you don't have to compete
for the pride but the pride is stronger
because it only has one lion uh the same
thing is true in in multiple different
types of societies and civilizations in
many ways we've structured our own Human
Experience to reward the apex predator
select this for that person correct and
then if only when that person times out
right after four years or eight years if
it's if it's the president or they never
time out if you consider a
congressperson to be an apex predator
right they just have to keep winning the
collective vote of their pride so in
many ways we we are people need that
tribally people need a tribal Elder they
need a tribal leader we forget that we
are a tribal animal
I learned a while ago about the
functional usefulness of psychopaths and
I asked this guy that researched
Psychopaths clinically he was going into
jails and speaking to them doing
interviews and stuff and he said
basically I was like look it's so
maladaptive for the group why would you
have a psychopath you know why is this
why has it not being competed out of the
gene pool people would have been killed
because they would have [ __ ] over too
many others you can't travel from town
to town you're in a Dunbar number of 100
or 150 or something you do this once or
twice and people are going to know what
your nature is and he said yes but
you're forgetting that smeared across an
entire population it's actually quite
useful to have Psychopaths if you need
to go and wreck lindesfarne as a group
of Vikings it's actually kind of useful
to have a group of 10 men that you can
throw in there that are going to have no
remorse about going and pillaging and
bringing back a load of gold okay well
that's that's kind of interesting and I
wonder whether
it's possible to look at
modern apex predator type individuals
with the same sort of lens that
absolutely yeah look this is a very
specific type of tool or weapon
depending on your point of view
and the choice is we have more than our
enemy our enemy has more than us
who do you want to be generating uh GDP
who do you want to be pushing Innovation
who do you want to be making the
strongest connections and networks not
only within this country but also
outside of this country now there is an
externality there's a risk here that
the more that that person gets power
the more dangerous that individual
becomes but they're dangerous in kind of
a predictable way sometimes and also
I'd rather have more Psychopaths on my
team than on somebody else's
yeah I think and what you're getting to
are fantastic conclusions that people
just don't often people are
uncomfortable analyzing a situation
to get to that point
do you do you want to have Navy Seals
that operate on behalf of the United
States or do you want to have do you
want to disband your Navy Seals and
instead have the Navy whatever a naval a
Navy cheerleading team that goes out
there and tries to make friends with
everybody you want cold hard Killers
When you need cold hard Killers you want
apex predators when you need apex
predators and what happens is we whoever
the leading Society is it was true with
the Romans it's true with us it's going
to be true with whoever becomes the next
great superpower in the world
that position of first place is a luxury
that we tend to take for granted we all
know what it was like in high school or
college if we were an athlete if you
were the best athlete on the team or if
your team was the best team in the
division whatever it might be everybody
just expects you to win and win and win
again and win again and win again and
then if you're ever beaten
the the loss is so much more devastating
than if you're the second or third best
team and you're used to taking hits and
you're used to winning and sometimes you
win sometimes you lose right this
there's a reason professional athletes
suffer from their own kind of Trauma
from the intense demands of performance
because we as a culture we actually like
Apex cold-hearted
Killers we like them and we celebrate
them in sports we celebrate them in in
in movies we like books about you know
assassins and killers and super spies
it's something that culturally we all
like and we all want and the reason is
because we all recognize there's a
certain level of security when you're
with the most proficient of Any Given
skill there is a functional utility to
being around the most dangerous weapon
in the room this is one of the reasons
put forwards by uh evolutionary
psychologist when I asked her why many
women seem to have an obsession with
dark romance and True Crime and for the
record I believe that mafia boss stories
are bloke's equivalence of True Crime
for chicks the guys that love learning
about Sammy the bull and about drug
kingpins and stuff you are not allowed
to look down on girls that love to learn
about true crime series Killers because
you are listening to the exact same
podcast it's just on the male side of
the fence but I asked this question
about why is it that these women and you
also find as well with serial killers
that um women fall in love with these
killers these guys are on death row and
women are sending them marriage
proposals and and gifts and all sorts of
stuff it's very dangerous
why is it that women seem to have this
particular Obsession and there's a bunch
of different reasons and maybe some of
them are all of them and all of them but
um
attaching yourself to somebody that is
incredibly dangerous uh Falls you under
the umbrella of their protection there
is also a an element of being able to be
better educated in order to protect
yourself like I need to know what I need
to avoid in order so that I don't get
attacked by it
um but yeah man I I do think that the
functional utility of having some
dangerous guys on your side of the of
the pitch is a difficult reality because
they are going to do things that you're
not going to be happy about and also
it's very right to say that we have um
it's very difficult to be at the top of
your game the top of any game and not
have people secretly waiting for your
downfall to unbelievably difficult line
to walk to be the best at what you do
whatever it is whatever field it is
whether it's podcasting or sports or
singing or something else
and
Rob Henderson one of my buddies shared a
an article a while ago about how one of
those I think four of the most popular
Heroes story arcs that are typical
and none of them included the person
that came into the story the hero and
left the story The Hero there is the
um Icarus the guy that starts at nothing
flies too close to the Sun and then
crashes there is the guy that starts
High Falls and then comes back a
Redemption there is a from nothing to
something and there is a fourth one as
well that I can't remember no one
no one wants the person that comes into
the world with everything and leaves
with everything everybody wants them to
fail yeah it's interesting and it's it's
difficult because it's uh for many
people that demotivates them from trying
to be the best for many people that
that's exactly the governor that keeps
them from taking it one step further or
or taking one you know one extra risk or
being vocal or being you know Face
Forward
um it's it's it's hard because when you
are when you're out there
as an athlete as a business owner as a
podcaster whatever you might be
you you do feel it you feel I mean you
don't even have to feel it you can read
it on Twitter there's plenty of people
out there chanting for your failure
every day if you don't know what it
looks like just look at look at my feet
and like there's people out there
chanting every day for me to fail and
that's that's just part of what it takes
to be
to be the person who's striving for more
if you want to be ignored and overlooked
by history nobody will ever send you
death threats but if you want to make a
splash if you want to make a ripple in
history you're going to piss people off
along the way you just have to learn to
accept it and that's one of the things
that when I'm around my my ultra high
net worth clients
it's really refreshing to me because
they're clients but they're also mentors
I am striving to try and be in their
shoes I'm learning from them every day
I'm learning what I want to be but I'm
also learning what I don't want to be
because to get to that level you've made
an incredible sacrifices to your health
in your family to your marriage right
like this there's some seriously
devastating circumstances that you're
ultra wealthy you're you're business
owners who we all think that it must be
so great to be Jeff Bezos it must be so
easy to be Mark Zuckerberg those guys
have not had easy lives do they have
money yes they have money but they have
problems that we don't want they don't
get to binge watch a Netflix series
that's not what that's not in their
Universe you know I get to cuddle with
my kids read them a bedtime story kiss
them on the forehead that's that's my
reality and I like that reality but
there's a lot of people out there your
apex predators don't get to do that
there was an idea I came up with about a
reverse role model so role models of the
aspirational version of what you want to
look up to a reverse role model is the
inversion of that it's the people who
have the traits that you don't want to
have and from where I come from in the
northeast of the UK there weren't many
people that were and perfectly like the
person I wanted to be but there were
many people who had individual
fallibilities that I definitely didn't
want and I could look around and say
okay I definitely don't want his
relationship with his family his
approach to gambling his approach to
finances the way that he treats his
partner all of these things and
I think a lot more success can be found
in life by avoiding ruin than by chasing
success you don't you don't ever get
completely killed out of the game
by not getting sufficient success but
you can do it by multiplying by zero
right it's the never multiplied by zero
Rule and
that to me is very reassuring for people
that feel like they don't have people
around them that they want to be like
like look I know that you might not have
an aspirational role model at the moment
but you can avoid failure and that is
not nothing that is a lot more than not
nothing that might be even
75 of what you're trying to do in life
is avoid failure that might be it might
be even more it might be 90 of what
involved is involved in success is
simply avoiding failure yeah and it's
funny because I I I love this whole idea
of a reverse role model I've never heard
before so thank you for for presenting
it I would say that just because failure
is a word that gets misunderstood and
misinterpreted so many ways when you
define it you're talking about don't be
like the reverse role model don't be
like this person who represents the
things that you don't value and the
things that you don't believe in so when
you call that person failure I agree but
the what ends up happening is a lot of
times people start to fear failure not
understanding that like failure is
totally fine trying and missing is
better than never trying at all
so the idea of run away from from the
negative role model is still taking you
somewhere and it may not be the place
that you're ultimately going but it's
definitely you're not running close to
the place that you don't want to go yes
that's a really cool visual when you
when you talk about that reverse role
model
what if you come to believe about
dealing with risk and putting yourself
out there and having a lean in mentality
you know you're somebody that was
working in a clandestine way in the
shadows with no public profile for a
long time and the last year or so has
been pretty wild for you in terms of
exposure and all that sort of stuff what
have you come to believe about that yeah
so what I believe about risk is a mix of
what I've experienced and then what I've
been trained one of the first things
that CIA trains us is to is to put
definitions around risk there's two
types of risk There's real risk and
there's perceived risk real risk is the
real quantifiable objective risk right
when you drive in a car you are actually
putting yourself at risk if you were
just walking on a sidewalk you're
objectively at less risk of a car
accident than when you drive in a car
you're whenever you pick up a weapon to
go to a shooting range you're putting
yourself at risk right those are real
tangible risks with real tangible
probabilities there is a probability out
there about the likelihood that you're
going to get in a car accident at any
given moment that's all real risk
perceived risk is the risk that most of
us deal with all the time
it's the fear that we have about getting
in a car accident even when we're not in
a car it's the fear we have about being
mugged just because we're in a city it's
the fear we have about making our boss
angry or disappointing our spouse or you
name it there's all these perceived
risks that we're constantly going
through in our head these what-if
scenarios these catastrophic scenarios
it's part of a of a cognitive
um there's something called cognitive uh
distortions
and there's a cat there's a specific
cognitive distortion called
catastrophizing and that's what we're
doing with perceived risk we're seeing
all the worst scenarios and believing
that they are somehow likely to happen
just because we can think of them
perceived risk and real risk are not the
same thing so CIA teaches us to focus on
real risk just because we're lying about
our name and going into a foreign
country and trying to steal Secrets
doesn't actually mean we're going to get
caught in fact it means that we're our
training and our preparation reduces the
probabilities that we're going to get
caught so the real risk is actually
quite low
so when I started my own journey of
becoming more public
I didn't I I had a background in
perceived in real risk the real risks to
me if I say something that violates my
secrecy agreement with CIA I'm gonna get
a knock on the door from from legal
counsel office of general counsel at CIA
I might get fined I might go to jail who
knows what might happen they're going to
shut down my business that's real risk I
might have somebody who just gets pissed
off about what I'm saying and they send
me you know cyanide in the mail I don't
know that's all real like there's a
potentiality for all these crazy things
but the probability isn't very high
especially not if I take steps to
protect myself protect my household make
sure I say the right things but if I let
myself focus on perceived risk oh well
what if I say something people don't
like or what if I say something that
people laugh at or what if I look goofy
in a video whatever it might be right
who cares like the the truth is that you
have to be able to calculate real risk
and then use real risk to weigh the risk
benefit scenario
if you're trying to weigh the risk
benefit scenario using perceived risk
you're always going to be
underestimating your ability to grow and
overestimating your risk factor so it's
it's all about understanding that risk
is important to success if you if you're
willing to take on more risk then you're
willing to embrace more success if you
hesitate to add the risk then you're
also holding back your potential for
great success the difficulty is that
people confuse the two you know
perceived risk can appear as real maybe
even more real than real risk people
would say well the real risk of
receiving some cyanide in the post is
very low that's okay but the risk of me
being stupid on the internet actually
maybe that is a big deal and the our
ability to lose rationality under
cognitive stress and under emotional uh
pain and fear is
pretty big it is but it's still just
perceived that's that's what's important
you got to go through the cognitive
exercise like just to use your example
saying something Goofy on the internet
you say something goofy you don't even
say something Goofy on the internet do
you remember when
who there was a musician
R Kelly there was a musician who
actually was like caught abusing females
pretty sure he's in jail now okay
so I don't even remember what happened
to him and I bet most of the people
listening to this right now don't
remember what happened to him but we all
remember that something happened to him
right we forget that time just I think
we talked about it earlier there's big
things and there's small things we
remember the big things we don't really
remember the small things so if you go
on the internet and say something silly
I've been on the internet and said
stupid stuff a thousand times
right those things fade away the things
that you do well are the things that
tend to last Arnold Schwarzenegger has
this awesome I feel like it's a TV
interview I wish I had a citation for it
but but somebody out there said you know
Arnold do you do you remember the worst
were the worst movie you were ever acted
in and he looked at the camera and he
was like oh yeah I remember the worst
movie I was ever in but nobody else does
right and I and I will forever remember
that because Arnold Schwarzenegger was
in some terrible [ __ ] movies man he
was in some horrible movies nobody
remembers those we remember all the
awesome Schwarzenegger movies right even
if you try to remember some of his bad
movies you might only come up with one
or two even though you may have watched
three or four go do a Google Search and
you'll be like I remember watching that
that was a bad movie that was a bad
movie that was a bad movie
The Human Condition we prioritize
information we choose to remember
certain things we remember macro things
with macro level emotions so if you or I
do something stupid on the internet five
days from now most people aren't going
to remember it it's got a pretty amazing
Half-Life and then it's gone so what's
the real risk
I would agree
I would say that there is a threshold
above which stupid things can become who
you are though truth I would I would say
that
um the internet's disposition to
smear people with negative
stories there are some people for whom
Joe Rogan will always be the n-word
compilation guy now and that's a man
who's put out more content than pretty
much anybody else alive right now right
the reason that that story trying to
take hold was typically they say look
this is the tip of the iceberg that we
know is his bigoted misogynistic racist
cisature normative patriarchal past
the problem and the reason that story
didn't take hold is because
most of the people that that story was
aimed at said I've seen the whole
Iceberg I've watched
200 500 a thousand hours of this guy you
can't try and tell me that there is
something lurking that I haven't seen
because the weight of evidence that I
have on the other side of the scale is
so great
that being said I think that
not doing something foolish
and and and dumb and silly that is
something which is almost
exclusively out of your control like
you're gonna make these little errors
regularly not doing something which is
career ending
is almost always within your control I
think that for the most part unless you
get unlucky and it's some strange
combination of situations this is
obviously on average right but the
Lion's Share of the the bell curve of
situations that could end you
you have to have not paid attention
you have to have gone to a a situation
without the uh requisite care and
attention and perhaps I'm uh creating a
little Cassandra complex for myself here
but my point being
with sufficient care I think that you
can avoid most of the big problems
um and the the point being once you
breach that threshold I do think that
people if you will always be your
greatest mistake to a lot of people
uh yeah I would agree I would agree with
that you will always be your biggest
mistake to a lot of people I love your
bell curve your bell curve visual right
there because so often we we forget that
there's a big fat Center to the bell
curve because all of the interesting
stories the things that most of us like
to talk about are not inside the bell
curve they're at the skinny end on
either side the people who are extremely
successful are the people who are total
failures nobody really likes to talk
about the middle class guy making 85 000
a year with a happy marriage and two
kids
that's just not an interesting person to
talk about so we end up talking about
these Fringe issues again going back to
real real risk and perceived risk there
will always be people who hate you
always even people who don't know who
you are right now if they were to find
out who you are there's always going to
be people who hate you that's a real
risk so what there's they're on the
small end of the bell curve because
let's be honest the fat end of the bell
curve most people aren't going to
remember you
you run a super successful podcast man
there's 300 million adult there's 300
million Americans 155 million adults
the vast majority of them they don't
know you they don't know me they're not
going to remember you they're not going
to remember me even Joe Rogan has that's
fantastically famous as he is right
there's a huge population out there that
just they don't they know of the name
but they've never watched an episode
they may never watch an episode it's
just the reality of it that's the bell
curve nobody likes to talk about we like
to talk about the fringes the people who
love you the people who hate you but
there's a whole group in the middle that
you kind of don't matter to them because
they're watching The History Channel
they're you know doing whatever trying
to just make it by make it through the
day we would care far less about what
other people think about us if we
realized how rarely they do exactly
right oh that's beautifully said man if
that's yours you need to write that down
someone's grandmother's and I'm gonna
guess she repurposed it from somebody
else there's a a really great concept
that I love it's called churchillion
Drift and it's a phenomenon whereby
quotes who have which have been
unattributed over time tend to converge
toward Churchill and this is how when
you Google pretty much anything on the
internet there's always an image a
square Instagram story that's called
Winston Churchill I also think there's
an Einstein drift as well a lot of them
get attributed to Einstein but uh it's a
genuine phenomenon it's you know I don't
know I don't know who said that I think
it was Churchill actually who said if we
didn't know how Riley people thought
about it well look uh Andrew bustamente
ladies and gentlemen if people want to
check out the stuff that you do online
where should they go sell sell them your
wares yeah absolutely you can go to my
website everydayspy.com or if you're a
podcast person you can go I have a an
iTunes top 10 podcast called the
everyday Espionage podcast it's on any
of your favorite platforms that are out
there and if you are on social media
then you're just looking for at everyday
spy on any social media and you'll find
me there Andrew I appreciate you thanks
man I appreciate it Chris take care
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]